hari shukla will be among those at the
front of the queue to be vaccinated
against covid19
the racial equality campaigner from
newcastle upon tyne in north
east england says it's a relief i
received a telephone call
i was very excited i feel you know that
it's good you know that i've got the
opportunity of doing that
and so i'm not nervous or anything like
that
i'm looking forward final preparations
are underway ahead of the largest
vaccination program
in british history batches of the pfizer
bioentech drug approved for use in the
uk
last week have been arriving from
pfizer's factory in belgium
the logistical challenge is immense the
vaccine needs to be kept at around
minus 70 degrees celsius i think we've
got everything we need now
in england 50 hospitals with facilities
to store the super chilled drug
will be the first to administer it
scotland wales and northern ireland will
also begin
similar programs in hospitals on tuesday
it's the
beginning of the end of this pandemic
we're not there yet
it's so important that people keep doing
the things we know we need to do
following the rules and the basics to
make sure we keep this under control
but we can now see the light at the end
of the tunnel
the government's ordered 40 million
doses so far
an initial 800 000 will be available in
the first round of treatment this week
capable of inoculating four hundred
thousand people
with two injections 21 days apart
this is one of several london hospitals
that will begin vaccinating this week
because initial supplies are limited
those at the front of the
line will be elderly people currently
receiving treatment in hospital
many others over the age of 80 have also
been contacted to come forward
and get their jabs and care workers who
look after the elderly have also been
prioritized if there are any doses left
they'll go to healthcare workers at
serious risk of contracting the virus
immunity starts to build after the first
dose
but becomes fully effective a week after
the second
in later phases of the rollout boxes of
the vaccine that come in packs of almost
a thousand doses
will be split up shared around the
country and defrosted
the vaccine can be stored at normal
fridge temperature but only for a few
days
as well as the logistical challenges the
government's also hoping to build
public trust in a vaccine developed and
approved
at record speed
in the wake of the pandemic conspiracy
beliefs have gained ground
a sizable minority of anti-vaccination
demonstrators believe the pandemic was
fabricated by government
and the vaccines designed to insert
people with microchips
according to researchers at oxford
university up to a quarter of the
population could be entertaining such
ideas
british scientists say stringent checks
have been carried out to ensure the
vaccine
safety and effectiveness the uk
is setting the pace for many other
countries what happens here
could be a game changer in the global
campaign against coronavirus
eve barker al jazeera london